yeah well equity
uh is another it's a synonym for
the sort of the obverse which is racism
and white supremacy i've been hearing
more my ears more attuned to biden's
endless repetition of systemic racism
and uh they're the same thing
i mean equity is the response to
systemic racism equity means
quotas it means the destruction of
meritocratic standards it means
you hire and promote on the basis of
race not on the basis of qualifications
and any institution which does not show
a proportional number
uh of of blacks or hispanics
is thereby by definition uh
systemically racist and engaged in bias
we have heard joe biden say the phrase
equity roughly 1 billion times
in his few weeks of uh i'll have to get
fact checked on that
but in his few weeks of office i mean
equity equity equity
you may remember that just what two or
three days before the election kamala
harris released that video on twitter
talking about that we should all end up
in the same place
this is obviously very different than
equality
are you kind of shocked or does it just
all fit that
that we sort of slipped equity under the
guise of equality into the system just
that quickly
where now if you say you're against
equity which is just sort of
an imaginary position uh well of course
you're racist and everything else
yeah well equity uh
is another it's a synonym for
the sort of the obverse which is racism
and white supremacy i've been hearing
more my ears more attuned to biden's
endless repetition of systemic racism
and uh they're the same thing i mean
equity
is the response to systemic racism
equity means
uh quotas it means the destruction of
meritocratic standards it means
you hire and promote on the basis of
race not on the basis of qualifications
and any institution which does not show
a proportional number
of of blacks or hispanics is thereby
by definition uh systemically racist and
engaged in bias
and and i'm fully expecting ibrahim
kendi
the big anti-racist uh uh huckster right
now who's probably the most highest paid
of them he may have even
bumped out tonight coates to end up in
the federal government and set up
a agency of anti-racism that will go
after
every private institutions using the
re the completely dangerous and
unjustified tool of disparate impact
which holds that any neutral process
such as saying
we expect you as a alzheimer's
researcher
to have a highly competitive knowledge
of the way neurology works
if that standard has a disparate impact
on blacks
then you get rid of the standard and say
we're going to replace it with quotas
the fact of the matter is
the academic skills gap in this country
is so vast that it is preposterous
to claim that the lack of proportional
representation
in any institution is the result of bias
the facts are these black 8th graders
54 of all black 8th graders in this
country
do not even have basic math skills
basic is defined by the national
association
of of educational progress the naep
as partial mastery
of math concepts 54 of black
8th graders are below basic in their
math skills 40 percent are below basic
in their reading skills that is
they do not even have partial mastery of
8th grade reading skills
that gap does not close it continues at
the sat level where you have a standard
deviation of gaap
lsats gmats mcats
everywhere you see that decision by the
way their response is
to now get rid of many of these things
right right exactly
they're going to get rid of that's why
they're getting rid of
the the sats and
my prediction is we are also eventually
going to get rid of crime data
you are going to have police departments
it's already
very hard uh to get your hands on
crime offending data and and criminal
victimization data as well
and that is eventually going to be
repressed as well
in order to further strengthen the phony
narrative
that the disproportion of blacks in the
prison system
is due to racism not to exponentially
higher rates of criminal offending
so i think when some people hear
you say that when they hear okay well 54
of black eighth graders aren't at at
that level
or the level that they should be at that
they say well then that proves that
their systemic racism
if if it's so disproportionate to black
people
i think at a surface level thought i
think that's what happens there so can
you just
can you just go a little bit beneath
that maybe as a comparison to the asian
community because i know you've written
a lot about that
well i proposed a thought experiment
which is that
if blacks acted like asians for 10 years
with all in all regards to things with
that have a bearing on
academic success on success in life
such as being fanatical about
school work you know having parents that
care about whether you're
going to class whether you're truant or
not
taking your textbooks home studying for
the next exam
not you know screaming at your teacher
beating up your teacher
not getting involved in drugs or gangs
having a very low out of wedlock birth
rate
if if all those behaviors were the same
and then we saw the socio-economic
disparities
that we do then it would be
more than enough time to start talking
about systemic racism
but right now you have a culture
and and you have addressed this dave
with your fantastic interview with
brandon of blexit
uh a inner city culture that
stigmatizes academic effort that
celebrates violence criminality
uh that is completely inimical to
success in life
when the behaviors are so different it
is way premature
to talk about systemic racism there is a
lot that can be
done at least in theory
i mean we've been trying for decades
without a whole lot of success
but it remains theoretically possible
to change the culture and the behaviors
that i think are
clearly related to the fact we don't
have
absolute equity in outcomes that
that kamala harris and biden uh pretend
to want and as long as we can no can't
talk about those behaviors
and we keep going down this path of
demanding more quotas
more transfer payments nothing is going
to change
and by the way of course the great
thomas soul has been talking about this
forever that that in effect is what the
welfare state did
do you think there's anything though the
government could do
let's say we had a government certainly
not the government we have at the
federal level now but if there was a
government
to come in and say okay we want to
address these issues around the family
around
generations on welfare all of these
things we want to address it
what do you do i mean i've heard some
people like candace owen say you just
you just stop the programs tomorrow and
you let that pain point hit
do you think there's a sensible policy
there do you say just end everything
what's the what's the actual action that
can happen
government cannot do social uplift it
doesn't know how to do it
and of course right now you have
government you know the social school
social work schools are cranking out
government workers that are utterly
committed
to non-judgmentalism when it comes to
self-destructive behavior
like i i remember in the six in the 90s
in new york i used to
write a lot about welfare reform and
would talk to these
uh non-profit workers and they were
adamant that they couldn't say a word
about out of wedlock childbearing which
is the biggest predictor of poverty in
this country
if if we could wipe out out of wedlock
child rearing
re-knit families together we'd get rid
of poverty and we'd get rid of
almost all crime and it's it's happening
now in the white community as well among
you know the the hillbilly elegy uh uh
population as well charles murray's
written about that uh so government does
not know
how to change people's upbringing
so yes it would be a great thing i would
absolutely back candace owens of going
cold turkey and there were proposals
uh about that for uh during the welfare
reform
era of the 19
of at least not giving more checks
larger checks when people had more
children out of wedlock but that was a
very hard sell
i would say government you know what
it's there for
is providing public order providing the
basis for people to exercise their own
initiative
that is above all safe streets so that
businesses
don't have to worry about their
employees they can set up shop
uh and and people can thrive and get
where they need to go without fear
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell